euh on a un gros gros programme Les
Chéries ce soir juste après tes PM duura
bienvenue au monastère à ne pas manquer
le nouveau programme de C8 qui envoie
Clara Morgane et d'autres célébrités
d'autres célébrités vivre dans un
monastère et sœur Catherine qui est dans
ce monastère qui est pour moi la star
programme si je le dis vous êtes la star
du
[Musique]
programme à ne pas manquer ce soir alors
on va revenir sur les extrait on va vous
montrer en exclusivité des extrait de ce
programme qui est qui est très attendu
alors ils n'ont pas le droit au
téléphone ils n'ont surtout pas le droit
de parler en journée vous rendez compte
pas le droit de parler toute la journée
vous rendez compte Gilles Verdez non
mais s rig la saison 2 je vais envoyer
Gill
Verdez on l'ueille on l'AC je veux Gill
Verdez l'année prochaine franchement je
veux Gilles verdz là-bas ver là-bas
franchement ça serait incroyable et et
Paul serait pas mal aussi ah ouais he
franchement Paula au monastère sans
téléphone en plus pour elle
c'estéé R couch à 20h30 Ahou à mais
franchement pa dans Bienvenue au
monastère pas mal a Daniel a pas besoin
est toute
l'année regardez ils n pas le droit de
parler en journée ce qui est un peu
compliqué pour les
candidats à défaut de pouvoir parler
tout est prétexte à rire même un frère
qui fait le signe de
[Musique]
croix
alors sœ Catherine dans l'émission vous
êtes la guide spirituelle des candidats
ça consiste en quoi en fait ce qui a été
très très beau dans ce cette émission
dans ce qu'on a fait ensemble à Corbara
c'est cette en fait des retraites on en
fait tout le temps et pour tout le monde
et c'est de faire plonger les gens dans
l'intériorité dans une un lien avec
l'intérieur avec nos entrailles avec
l'invisible et donc euh ils étaient donc
une semaine en silence et on les
accompagnait pendant cette semaine donc
ils avaient 20 minutes de temps avec
nous on pouvait échanger sur différents
sujets qui étaient de plus en plus
profonds au fur et à mesure de la
semaine euh vous avez accepté tout de
suite de de le faire ou pas quand on
vous a prop proposé le truc quand on
vous a dit ça va être ça le euh il va se
passer ça ça va être un programme pour
pour la télé est-ce que vous avez dit
oui tout de suite alors on a l'habitude
de faire des retraites ça c'est il y a
pas de souci j'ai l'habitude mais là les
le fait que ce soit filmé c'était quand
même quelque chose d' exceptionnel mais
j'ai dit oui parce que je sentais que
c'était là ma place alors vous avez
l'habitude de faire des retraites ils
ont l'habitude d'être à
l'ARM et d'être filmé exactement et et
c'est vrai que il y a des moments
incroyables notamment ce moment avec
avec Clara Clara Morgan qui explique son
métier au monastère euh alors ton métier
voilà c'est très voilà et c'est vrai que
tu trouves toujours les les bon mot toi
ben moi j'ai l'impression de faire le
bien de parler d'amour de on parcourt
les routes de France avec mon spectacle
de cabaret devant en ce moment 1000
personnes c'est une communion absolue et
moi je ne parle que d'amour donc je me
sens très connectée à la sœur même si
effectivement bon ben ça peut faire rire
et même nous on trouve ça antinomique
mais en réalité quand on d'amour quand
on est bienveillant quand on est
tolérant et bien on est pareil et on a
énormément de points communs et c'est
c'est très c'est très déstabilisant de
se rendre compte à quel point on a des
points communs on est né exactement la
même année on a le même parcours de vie
c'est incroyable on a pas fini par mais
on a le même parcours de vie on a été
élevé par les Dominicaines toutes les
deux on a perdu quelqu'un à 11 ans qui
nous a éloigné de la religion moi je n'y
suis pas revenue et en 2001 j'ai décidé
de et bien de de prendre un grand virage
une grande décision en venant à Paris à
19 ans et en fait c'est la même année où
sœur Catherine est rentrée dans les
ordre pour des raisons aussi en fait
assez similaires et ça prouve qu'on peut
faire des choix vraiment très différent
en étant presque pareil fondamentalement
il y il y a beaucoup de choses qui nous
relient et je trouve que c'est un très
beau message pour l'humanité et j'ai
insisté pour qu'elle vienne ce soir
parce que sœur Catherine n'aime pas
tellement se mettre en avant alors
comment vous avez pris vre
dantna pas qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous
êtes venu c'est on vous a dit que
j'étais gentil bien on m'a dit que vous
étiez gentil ça ça a joué beaucoup et
puis Clara m'a appelé elle m'a dit ce
serait beau qu'on le fasse ensemble et
pour moi ça avait du sens en fait je me
suis dit cette retraite qu'on a vécu
avec ces six retraitants qui était
j'avoue he je ne connaissais personne
Clara Morgan je connaissais pas et c que
même
moi en fait on a beaucoup de point
commun nous aussi et et et et c'est vrai
que franchement le programme il est il
est incroyable regardez on va voir
l'extrait là je par l'extit donc je
parla
avec ça va bah oui toi mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait là je sais pas encore on a un
message moi je suis artiste de cabaret
productrice de mon propre spectacle j'ai
une autre
activité dédiée on va dire au couple à
l'amour donc ça passe par la lingerie et
par plein de de petites choses pour
pimenter la vie des
couples ouais alors c'est ce soir dans
le monastère Clara vous avez tout de
suite accepté quand vous vous la
proposez honnêtement le titre m'a amusé
je me suis dit à Clara Morgan au
monastère même moi j'ai envie de voir
même moi j'ai envie de découvrir j'adore
les chos m'ava demandé d'ailleurs
comment m'avez demandé bah oui oui bien
sûr mais je même pas au courant moi
j'étais même pas au courant qu'on
l'avait demandé et elle me dit ouis on
m'a demandé de faire bienvenue au
monastère je dit bah écoute bah c'est
c'est c'est la chaîne sur dans laquelle
tu es j'avais envie de de savoir si
c'était un programme bienveillant parce
qu'il y a que ça qui m'intéresse et
surtout si ce n'était pas un programme
catholique religieux et ça c'était très
important pour moi parce que je ne suis
pas catholique euh parce que je suis
très spirituelle je m'intéresse
énormément à la théologie les religions
m'intéressent parce que je trouve que
elle divergent mais que le le point
central reste la connexion à l'univers à
plus grand que soi au mystère ça
m'intéresse énormément et j'ai envie de
savoir j'ai envie de questionner sœur
Catherine pour savoir comment elle prie
pourquoi elle prie pour qui elle prie
elle prie énormément pour nous pour le
programme pour ce soir par exemple ça
m'intéresse beaucoup et je tiens à dire
que ce n'est pas du tout un programme
catholique ni qui veut tirer la
couverture vers le côté ce n'est pas ça
on parle d'introspection de spiritualité
d'échange et surtout de tolérance envers
des gens qui ne sont pas du même monde
mais qui s'aime qui réussiss à s'imer
Caine racontez-nous un peu votre
histoire vous vous étiez comment vous
étiez vos parents étaient religieux
comment ah oui ben pour euh faire très
très rapidement je j'ai grandi dans une
famille catholique pratiquante et comme
disait Clara à l'âge de 11 ou 12 ans euh
j'ai perdu un frère d'un accident de
moto et ça a été pour moi un choc assez
fort parce que je me suis dit mais
comment on peut dire que Dieu est Amour
que Dieu veut notre bonheur parce que
moi aussi j'avais été élevé dans une
école de religieuse comme Clara on a
beaucoup de points en commun et là je me
suis dit euh ben non j'en ai pas besoin
donc j'ai décidé un peu de vivre euh
sans lui entre gu guillemet en me disant
ben je vais m'en sortir toute seule et
euh donc quand j'avais 18 ans mes
parents qui ont vu parce que quand même
extérieurement tout allait bien j'avais
plein de potes je sortais je faisais la
fête j'allais boire des bières ça cétait
très important pour moi et je restais
sage quand même et en fait mes parents
qui ont vu queil y avait quand même une
tristesse qui s' inststallait dans mon
cœur se sont dit ben euh on va lui
proposer les JMJ c'est un Journée
Mondiale de la Jeunesse un truc pour des
jeunes qui réunit des jeunes du monde
entier autour du pape et c'était à Rome
et donc moi j'étais à Rome pour faire la
fête rencontrer des gens rencontrer
d'autres nationalités voir Rome euh
voilà et c'était tout et là-bas en fait
j'étais bouleversé par la joie
qu'avaient les jeunes qui étaient autour
de moi il rayonnaient de quelque chose
qui m'attirait et donc j'ai fait cette
prière à l'intérieur de mon cœur en
disant à Dieu si tu existes vraiment je
veux que tu me le montres concrètement
dans ma vie et c'est 8 mois plus tard
j'allais prier dans des églises euh en
demandant vraiment j'avais dit je te
donne une année pour que tu me montres
que tu vraiment et 8 mois plus tard j'ai
clairement perçu à l'intérieur de mon
cœur vraiment dans dans mes entrailles
que Dieu était là qu'il était présent
qui m'avait toujours aimé et qu'il avait
toujours été là dans ma vie et cette
date c'est 2001 c'est ça correspond
c'est ça qui est beau quand on s'est
retrouvé c'est que ça correspondait et
du coup c'est pour ça aussi que je suis
là ici ce soir parce que en fait je suis
très heureuse d'être parmi vous parce
que pour moi ce programme il est attessé
à tous pour moi ce en fait Dieu il est
pour tous infini est pour tous et et
l'amour il est pour tous et c'est ça
aussi qui nous retrouve qui nous
rassemble avec Clara elle est pas
extraordinaire euh c'est parce que en
fait ouais c'est on a tous soif d'infini
et vous voyez dans ce monde où on a on a
de plus en plus de de de de mauvaises
nouvelles vous allez vous allumz la télé
la radio c'est c'est crche quoi et en
fait euh en fait ben nous on vous
propose un programme de lumière un
programme où vous serez heureux euh on
peut où les gens peuvent s'interroger
sur leur spiritualité voil et je trve
que Ren qu'il see la question le Paris
peut être réussi alors est-ce qu'il y en
a qui sont religieux ici autour de la
table religieux Daniel is c'est c'est
quoi comment comment ça se matérialise
comment bah non mais je enfin je suis
très ému parce que c'est la joie je me
suis retrouvé dans ce dans ce parcours
de jeunesse quoi en fait excusez-moi
c'est pasve mais c'est vrai que quand
j'ai perdu mon père j'ai j'ai plus cru à
Dieu enfin je l'en voulais tellement à
12 ans de perdre son père c'est
tellement injuste et puis puis moi aussi
vers 18 ans je suis revenu et j'ai j'ai
j'ai attendu un signe c'est exactement
ce que j'ai ressenti c'est incroyable
quoi donc excusez-moi mais c'est c'est
pas grave merci merci mais moi il n' pas
fait de signe et puis j'étais peut-être
aussi dans la futilité j'ai choisi j'ai
choisi une voie de futilité mais bon
voilà mais c'est c'est incroyable ce que
vous me racontez parce que je me suis
retrouvé ce qui est le plus frappant
chez sœur Catherine c'est qu'elle a
décidé de n'être que joie il a que ça
qui importe peu importe le président de
la République hier elle m'a fait rire
pardon je peux me permettre tu
non demandis qui était Gabrielle àal par
qu'elle s'en fiche complètement et il y
a le chauffeur qui lui dit vous savez
qu'on a changé de Premier ministre éta
es même pas au courant parce que en fait
nous on est tellement connecté non mais
c'est c'est beau on est on est connecté
à cette réalité incessante qui qui enfin
je veux dire la on veut les infos on
veut être connecté on veut et en fait
sœur Catherine en fait elle veut juste
que les gens soient heureux elle t toute
sa vie parce que je peux dire ce qui est
ta vie oui comme elle déballe ma vie
allons-y je vais faire je vais faire
simple en fait sœur Catherine a donné sa
vie aux jeunes via sa communauté elle va
aider des jeunes dans la rue qui sont
délinquants qui peuvent être désœuvré ou
abandonné et elle apporte leur son aide
en fait elle a donné sa vie à l'humanité
elle a renoncé à être mère elle a
renoncé à son ego elle a et moi je
trouve ça tellement inspirant quand on
se sent une bonne personne et qu'on est
face à sœur Catherine et bien on un peu
tout en cause parce que nous on agit par
ego parce que voilà bien sûr que on a
envie d'être humaniste mais elle est la
vraie humaniste je pense que dans ce
monde où c'est c'est marant c'est vous
qui lisez beaucoup
Ossa qui est un philosophe qui parle
Mossa pas des cuisines ai ça je connais
pas
ça parle de l'accélération et en fait il
parle de la résonance et je pense qu'on
est tous appelés à éc éc cette résonance
qui est en nous cette vibration qui est
en nous et qui est adressée à tous c'est
M qui a dit ça non
[Rires]
m joue Bayern je dernière non mais
j'adore j'adore franchement moi je peux
écouter sur Catherine pour autant vous
non autant sur Catherine oui sur
Catherine il paraît que vous avez rêvé
de de l'émission avant de venir c'est
quoi l'histoire j'ai beaucoup non j'ai
beaucoup prié avant de venir ici pour
moi c'est complètement
nouveau hein de venir sur un plateau
voilà exactement je suis très heureuse
de bah de voir tous et de voir tous ceux
qui regardent et et regarder l'émission
en fait vous allez être touché par cette
émission qui s'adresse à tous qui est
universelle les six retraitants que moi
j'ai découvert Jean-Marc Généreux Simon
Castaldi Fabien Cara Delphine Vesper
Paul ELCA notre bienaimée Clara ils
étaient tous en fait ils ont tous joué
le jeu ils ont tous joué le jeu du du du
silence de se couper du monde de
l'intériorité il par un peu il y en a
qui ont pas réussi hein mais on a essayé
et en fait ça ça a donné des choses qui
sont très très fortte très très belle et
que vous verrez tout au long du de l'
merci sur Catherine merci clair d'être
avec nous